all right so you've got a disrespectful
wife so what's happening we were at a
date and I love wearing my trump hat out
in public it was you know truck 2020 hat
she's like oh well you can't wear that
when we're going out in public together
I went with it at first and then I had
my doubts I was like is she gonna keep
on talking to me like this this is an
example for those of you that are
watching of what one concession looks
like in betatization through a thousand
concessions I'm willing to bet since she
said she's disrespectful she's done this
more than once tonight it was the toilet
seat she was like you have to put the
toilet seat down after you use the
toilet I'll tell you what your problem
is Bob is that yes you're unplugged but
you're still a beta women will [ __ ] test
you for your competency and you've
already failed a bunch of those [ __ ]
tests to be honest with you something
like this to try to fix it is very hard
you guys have kids no kids and she's not
pregnant cut ties get divorced call it a
[ __ ] day once you figure yourself out
and you level yourself up you know you
develop yourself as a man you know
become the unplugged Alpha sort of thing
then you'll be in a better position to
make better choices